die holen sind die verwundbarste stelle
eines mannes warum bauen sie dann so
schutzlos draußen herum in den männer-
und hosen welt gibt es grob zwei typen
erstens die boxershorts zweitens die
klassischen eng anliegenden unterhose
welche freunde sagen mir dass
boxershorts generell angenehmer zu
tragen sind es sei denn man möchte in
eine enge röhrenjeans rein dann weiß man
nicht wohin mit dem ganzen stoff
allerdings liebe männer solltet ihr wohl
generell auf enge unterleibs mode
verzichten da zum beispiel enge
unterhosen die hoden temperatur erhöhen
weil sie die hohen näher an den körper
an drücken anstatt sie frei baumeln zu
lassen
die eier hängen nämlich nicht umsonst
draußen herum nur so bleiben sie nämlich
schön kühl und zwar etwa 2 bis 5 grad
unterhalb der körpertemperatur also ich
kann dir nur empfehlen
biologisch gesehen unsere mode völlig
unlogisch wissenschaftler haben nämlich
festgestellt dass die spermaqualität mit
dem tragen enger unterhosen ablehnt zb
indem der anteil beschädigter dna
zunimmt
inwieweit sich dass es aber tatsächlich
auf potenz und fruchtbarkeit aus gibt
darüber sind sich die forscher noch
nicht einig vorsichtshalber kann es aber
nicht schaden die engen boxen erst mal
im schrank zu lassen und auch
boxershorts zurückzugreifen
wahrscheinlich freut dass auch eure
partner oder bietet ihr das stimmt hier
oben ab langes rumsitzen soll übrigens
auch die hohen temperatur erhöhen
deswegen geht raus bewegt euch aber
vorher lassen es noch ein abo dann sehen
uns nämlich nächsten donnerstag wieder
und wenn ihr noch themenvorschläge habt
sachen habt ihr euch schon immer gefragt
habt dann reine mit ihnen die kommentare
und wir sehen uns der nächste woche
wieder dabei schön schlau